[Música]
a apresentação se chama o futuro do
homem o que vem depois do homem né
porque a gente está num momento em que
as coisas acontecem muito rápido as
tecnologias mudam o tempo todo tem
notícia o tempo todo nova tecnologia
inteligência artificial blog em robótica
edição genética como a gente consegue
acompanhar isso né ea idéia é que essas
novas tecnologias não só mudam a forma
como a gente se relaciona com o mundo e
as coisas mas também como nós definimos
o que é ser humano diante dessas novas
tecnologias
então é basicamente isso que eu vou
falar só que em vez de tratar do já
chegar no futuro eu queria trazer um
pouco do passado há 500 mil anos quando
a espécie humana estava se desenvolvendo
e os primeiros registros que a gente tem
que eu queria mostrar aqui mas não tá
parecendo são de alguns é registros de
pólen de flores que foi escondido
encontrado junto com cadáveres de homens
de neandertal o que significa que
naquela época o homem diante da morte
ele teve noção de que compra lidar com
essa inevitabilidade ele precisava fazer
rituais para tentar lidar com isso e aí
o que isso significa autores como edgar
morra os bambis trina ou mesmo floyd
falam à seguinte questão o ser humano é
o único que sabe que vai morrer é o
único que tem a consciência da própria
morte
diferente de animais como gato o
elefante que se afastou quando estão
morrendo eles fazem isso quando eles
estão morrendo
o ser humano ele tenha consciência de
que vai morrer então pra quem viu coco
da pizza por exemplo tem aquela história
da cultura mexicana das três mortes
a primeira morte quando em algum momento
da sua vida você entende que você vai
morrer
a segunda morte é quando você morre de
verdade ea terceira morte quando ninguém
mais se lembra de você então a idéia de
memória é muito muito forte para os
seres humanos ea gente tenta sobreviver
através da memória como defendia o vila
influência através de sejam cultos de
rituais de religião de moralidade como a
família de cultura e de arte então a
idéia da arte é muito importante pra
isso aqui do centro dos homens de
neandertal
então a idéia de sobreviver através da
imagem é aquela idéia de permanecer vivo
na memória
mesmo que essas imagens durem mais mil
anos como essas
pinturas rupestres e imagens que foram
encontrados nas cavernas é um sinal de
que eu estive aqui é uma marca que no
tempo fica registrado a existência de
uma pessoa e assim ela vive para sempre
como memória e é interessante que da
arte na origem da palavra na grécia
antiga era conhecido como mi meses
portanto mímese cópia da realidade e
quando a gente vê obras como a odisséia
a gente vê que o liceo ele convivia com
criaturas mágicas como grifo sykora
ciclopes e ninfas mas é porque naquela
época não existia uma separação entre um
plano divino eo plano físico plano
racional
hoje nós vivemos em um mundo e uma época
bastante secular mas naquela época as
criaturas mágicas e os deuses andavam
entre as pessoas então quando a odisséia
refletia isso na literatura no teatro ou
então na arte grega era porque essa era
a realidade deles então a arte é uma
representação da realidade isso muda
quando criou o cristianismo se
implementa na europa
a arte deixa de ser tratada como mimi
cepa seja é relacionada com a palavra e
mago que deu origem à imagem e mago
nesse sentido é a idéia de imagem de
deus o homem à imagem de deus
a arte à imagem de deus ao mesmo tempo
em que os artistas eram subjugados ao
clero porque eram eles que pra mim é dar
um patrocínio aos artistas e eles assim
figuravam as narrativas do cristianismo
também ela estava falando de uma no
outro de um outro plano divino que era
muito real naquela época apesar de ter
artistas como michelangelo que trazia
uma versão mais humanista na arte isso
muda quando a gente tem um ilumine o
iluminismo ea gente passa a ter uma
mentalidade mais racionalista começa a
não tão é se focar no mistério da fé mas
sim em questões olímpicas em leis da
física em coisas mais racionais que
podem explicar o mundo que não há fé
então o iluminismo trás disse com com
essa pensamento e acaba rompendo com
esses dois planos o plano do divino eo
plano físico para se focar apenas no
plano racional
só que isso acaba eliminando uma forma
de entender o mundo então a gente tem
alguns pequenos problemas como a
consciência como eu vá parar e fala que
a gente precisa resolver ainda e às
vezes o plano científico nem sempre
resolve todos os problemas quando a
gente conseguir resolver essa questão da
consciência talvez as coisas mudem muito
bem como a gente percebe
quando e como a gente percebe a própria
humanidade e essa idéia de plano do
divino plano do físico é muito
importante quando a gente pensa por
exemplo na obra divina comédia de dante
alighieri não existia na narrativa da
bíblia cristã
a idéia de espaços do inferno então
círculos do inferno online na divina
comédia que isso inaugurado só que é o
mais interessante é que como uma autora
fala margaret whiting ela fala que essa
idéia de círculos do inferno do inferno
o plano divino plano físico l relação à
nossa especialidade especialidade com a
nossa própria indivíduo como a gente se
relaciona como ser então quando dante
alighieri que cria essa noção de espaço
através da literatura ele também ajuda
os artistas a pensar em uma nova técnica
que a técnica da perspectiva e com isso
eles representam através da arte uma
realidade que é a nossa que é ter
objetos mais distantes e outros mais
próximos enquanto que a arte antes era
achatada com isso a gente pode ter uma
nova percepção de como a arte reflete a
realidade como nós nos enxergamos na
realidade através dessa noção espacial e
também curiosamente o dante alighieri
ele criou essa palavra trânsito manar no
na divina comédia porque vigília quando
ele vai pro mundo dos mortos ele está
vivo ainda então ele transcende a
condição de humano dele ele não é vivo
nem morto ele é uma outra coisa e essa
noção de transmontana diz superar e de
expandir a questão humana de ser além do
humano ela ganha várias outras roupagens
ao longo da história da humanidade isso
por exemplo acontece do ano da transição
entre o século 19 e século 20 quando na
rússia o cosmu russo falava sobre como
nós podemos expandir como espécie
para além do espaço então a ideia é a
terra é finita e as mas a espécie humana
não pode acabar portanto vamos expandir
pelo espaço vamos colonizar outros
planetas não se trata apenas de um
astronauta mas sim de um cosmonauta é
criar realmente um copo para que a
espécie humana continua expandindo e não
se acabe nunca essa idéia chega nos
estados unidos de uma forma um pouco
diferente durante a guerra fria alguns
com os mísseis russos e membros da
igreja ortodoxa russa vão pra praia para
os estados unidos para lidar com a
iminência de uma possível guerra nuclear
de bombas nucleares quando ele chegou lá
com a narrativa de expandir o ser
olhando para o universo e também a
narrativa de viver para sempre no reino
de deus da igreja ortodoxa
os tecnólogos do vale do silício pegam
essa idéia e traduzem com a partir do
ponto de vista liberalista dos estados
unidos então nós temos o trânsito
humanismo como uma forma de usar a
tecnologia para expandir o homem através
do próprio corpo como podemos usar a
tecnologia para superar as nossas
limitações como é o caso da morte isso
tem muito relacionado com religião neto
que tem alguns movimentos como o
movimento terá assim que se chama de
trança religião em que o grande mote é
deus a tecnologia ea morte pode ser
superada isso é muito importante quando
a gente pensa em transformar nismo
porque se a morte definir a gente como
uma forma de criar esses subterfúgios
que de significado a esse sentido que a
gente sabe que vai morrer e por isso não
tem sentido à vida então você querer
superar a morte que a emancipá dela muda
todo o conceito do que é ser humano e aí
tem alguns projetos interessantes como
esse criado pelo empresário russo
dimitri cove que chama antônio flávio
iniciativa militar esse roadmap de
inovação na então a ideia é que 2015 e
2020 as pessoas possam controlar um
corpo robótico através de interfaces
cérebro máquina pra depois no futuro
conseguir transplantar o cérebro eo
corpo robótico e até depois talvez ter o
nosso próprio indivíduo emulado no
cérebro eletrônico
mas como fica isso dentro da
neurociência e da filosofia existem
algumas vertentes que falam que o euro
não está só no no cérebro também está no
corpo e também se expande como fica
realmente essa mentalidade é porque nos
anos 80 e 90 era muito forte isso no
trânsito humanismo a idéia da mente
acima da matéria a mente acima do corpo
o corpo é algo dispensável o que parece
muito ficção científica né é
interessante porque foi o irmão do ao
dos reis leite escreveu admirável mundo
novo o juliano jackson e que trouxe
novamente a idéia de transformar na área
de trânsito humanismo contemporaneamente
no começo do século 20 ele é até um
pouco mais próximo do que a gente
entende como transumanismo hoje e essa
idéia de superar o corpo superar e tem
somente como grande mestre do que é o
nosso ser é muito parecido com o que a
gente bem inseridos como alterar de
carbono no qual a gente consegue
supostamente trânsito
o nosso eu pra uma cápsula e transferir
essa cápsula por vários corpos que são
descartáveis que são em última instância
capas e o que só acontece o que é
discutido na sua série como na verdade
as pessoas que sobrevivem 300 anos o
infinitamente são as pessoas mais ricas
então é por isso que alguns filósofos
como francis fukuyama falam que o
transgênico pode ser a ideia mais
perigosa do mundo e da nossa época
porque isso pode criar uma diferença
entre as poucas pessoas uma divisão é
classe ao muito maior do que a gente vê
hoje se ricos já vivem mais do que
pobres hoje talvez isso melhores piore
ainda mais conforme essas tecnologias
forem sendo desenvolvidas e não sejam
popularizadas então por outro lado
quando a gente pensa nessa relação
homem-máquina a gente também pensa em si
borghi smuda é originalmente o termo ele
foi criado nos anos 60 por cientistas da
nasa que supunham que propunham o
seguinte a gente muda o nosso próprio
corpo para poder se adaptar a ambientes
inóspitos fora do planeta e tem mais eu
criar uma base lunar uma base marciana
eu mudo meu corpo para me adaptar ao
ambiente que eu não consigo sobreviver
naturalmente isso foi absorvido por esse
coletivo de artistas espanhóis a reboque
foundation de um ponto de vista bastante
amigável com relação à natureza então
uniu harbison é o primeiro cyborg
reconhecido por uma nação no mundo ele
nasceu sem conseguir enxergar cores e
ver tudo em preto e branco se juntou
alguns professores de universidade criou
o implante de antena que sai diretamente
do crânio dele e traduz as cores em
ondas eletromagnéticas portanto ele
criou um novo sentido ele percebe o
mundo a partir de umas de uma percepção
sinestésica e o interessante é que eles
defendem é que essas tecnologias e esses
implantes que com que aumenta a
capacidade deles na verdade são
inspiradas na própria natureza então por
que uma provocação muito interessante
que eles fazem é porque a gente tem luz
elétrica porque a gente não enxerga a
noite se a gente conseguisse chegar à
noite será que seria necessário ter luz
elétrica
será que seria necessário devastar
natureza cria hidrelétricas em última
instância girar eles assis que acabam
com a nossa própria espécie além de
outras talvez não então essas são
provocações de como ele fala não vamos
disse
na natureza porque podemos mudar o nosso
corpo e nos adaptar à forma que ela é e
não o contrário
por outro lado subculturas como o maior
hacker eles têm uma perspectiva que vai
desde as coisas mais acessórios como um
chip nfc implantado na mão até algumas
coisas mais extremas como colocou
arledge embaixo da pele também tem
alguns ambos bill hackers que já fizera
experimentação de injetar um líquido no
olho pra conseguir enxergar no escuro
por algum tempo então é uma subcultura
mais de nicho e que explora coisas mais
perigosas digamos assim
mas que é o primeiro começo pra gente se
pensar como a gente pode mudar o corpo
humano através de próteses através de
tratamentos genéticos e outras
tecnologias
e essa idéia de prótese também ela passa
ela deixa de ser só uma questão voltada
para pessoas com deficiência física a
gente começa a pensar que próteses na
verdade pode ser muito mais
interessantes do ponto de vista de
performance do que os nossos próprios
corpos orgânicos e com o qual a gente
nasceu uma pessoa que tem pernas
prostéticas corre muito mais rápido tem
muito mais força nas pernas do que
pessoas que não têm essa prótese no
momento que a gente vê essa admite
desmistificação das pessoas que têm
próteses de não ser uma pessoa que tem
uma deficiência mas que sim tem uma
potência quando a gente vê cantoras com
uma vitória modesta que é tipo uma lady
gaga cyborg a gente vê que tem próteses
interessantes que têm próteses que
inaugura uma nova experiência do que é
ser cyborg de que talvez existam próximo
gênero que não é um homem nem mulher mas
sim cyborg como a dona raul e defende e
com isso a gente passa a pensar qual vai
ser esse futuro como nós queremos que
esse futuro seja será que em algum
momento vamos querer na verdade tirar os
nossos próprios membros
as saudáveis e que nascemos com eles pra
te membros que amplifiquem a nossa
capacidade seja do ponto de vista físico
ou cognitivo ou será que vamos querer
outras coisas será que estamos mais
preocupados em ir para marte ou será que
estamos mais preocupados em acabar com a
fome com a sede no brasil então é muito
interessante a gente pensa de como essa
tecnologia ela na verdade a dar um salto
na evolução das espécies que demora
milhares de anos por seguir a natureza
do jeito tradicional
então a gente tem a teoria darwiniana
sobrevivência dos mais fortes o que a
gente vê através da tecnologia é
em vez de ser bairro off the fittest nós
temos o bairro off the richest que isso
pode acabar gerando o pai tarde entre as
classes como eu como pai pra vocês
por isso é muito importante que a gente
tenha consciência dessas mudanças dessas
tecnologias para que a gente não fique
com aquela postura de vítima as coisas
vão acontecer e eu não vou ficar sabendo
eu simplesmente vou aceitar e vai acabar
como exterminador do futuro na verdade
todos nós construímos isso todos nós
somos protagonistas dessa construção ea
evolução vai ser inscrita pela gente
esperamos que não seja uma distopia mas
sim um futuro positivo para todos
obrigada